[Music]
as a journalist when I came across
something horrific something I wanted to
turn away from
I couldn't
I hope you'll follow me however dark it
may be truth be told deals with the
themes of Truth and Justice throughout
the seasons this season the cases
surround missing girls and the truth
about why they go missing who gets
National media coverage who gets media
coverage at all
truth be told telling the truth is
actually one of the hardest things for
most people in season three I play a
high school principal where a number of
our students are being trafficked so
this season Poppy's podcast is solving
some of the crimes against these girls
puppy has to deal with how much of the
truth she wants to tell Justice doesn't
always have truth in it I think we
explore that beautifully the more poppy
delves into Drea's case the more she
realizes that sex trafficking is a huge
issue
dealing with topics that are very
relevant in today's society
you say things that other people can't
I'll get a few of my guys to help me do
some digging there's so many new
Dynamics we've really pushed the
envelope we delved into a very real
problem in a very authentic way
Gabrielle I feel extremely blessed to be
working opposite
when we first meet Eva there's a
mysteriousness around her I hope I
didn't get you into trouble only the
good kind poppy has to question is she a
friend or Foe they each come with a host
of Secrets there is a constant push and
pull between the two of them that makes
their relationship very combustible some
untruths are worth it this could ruin my
entire career we can't let him get away
with this I know do you their approach
to the same goal is just kind of wildly
different that's the beauty I think of
season three that it's not obvious
there's Mysteries within the Mysteries
we're constantly playing in these
emotional playgrounds and just trying to
peel back more and more layers I'm
excited for people to see the growth in
all the characters season three gives us
all an opportunity to really explore
some of the personal ups and downs the
characters are going through it's a
really expensive story but at its heart
is the dynamic of family there's a text
you're in a grit to it it's really
moving to be a part of we get to laugh
with them we get to cry with them we get
to mourn with them the truth is messy it
can be a little painful it can be dark
but also gives us glimmers of Hope which
is all that we can really ask for